football is providing some much-needed
respite for afghan refugees in qatar
hundreds have found a temporary home in
accommodation built for next year's
world cup
last month fifa president gianni
infantino was a guest player at a
coaching session that had been organized
by qatar 2022's generation amazing
legacy project
23 year old saeed worked in afghanistan
for an american tv network he arrived in
doha in august but had to leave his
parents and younger brother behind
football has always had its effect on me
i don't i know it it has effects on
everybody that who loves playing
footballers just playing football when
the boys were here before that they were
depressed they were thinking about what
will happen to today and what are they
going to do
and then we played football for a couple
of hours actually for myself for me i
thought everything is fine i'm back home
i'm playing football
since it began over a decade ago qatar
2022's generation amazing project has
reached more than half a million people
in countries all over the world and it's
not just football facilities being
provided here setting up a routine for
the children involving informal
schooling was just as important did you
know that these trees grow in salt water
and can be as tall as six a lot of these
children and families are their final
destination is an english-speaking
country which is totally understandable
so we started by offering english
classes and different
art and
music activities the fact that they're
in such a chaotic time in their lives
we'd like to offer them some sort of
routine it took a few days to establish
the space
but now that they know that we're here
every day and we care about them and
we're meeting their needs we're
listening to them
step one i feel with all of the kids is
come in sit with me let's draw something
that's why you have to find so much
artwork
because that's sort of like the most
primal
form of self-expression right almost
everyone who sits down to draw for me
their first drawing is a drawing of a
house or a home
or some sort of structure so i think
that speaks to the idea that they're
looking for home that they're
in a transitional
state
this may not be a permanent home but for
now qatar is providing these children
with a safe place to play and learn andy
richardson al jazeera doha